um you worked with young slobby before
he passed away talk about your guys's
relationship obviously rest in peace to
him but you know that was a big loss for
Stockton RP my Mary since I tapped
in with him like you feel because he
just been genuine for it as my
like I call that like we just talk
on some other not even on no music
for real like he'll come pull up on
me you feel me uh I I line little plays
up from for him to go get this so you
send me all type of little as my
RP that man well I really
with mostly I with a lot of
ebk though I ain't gonna lie I
with Jack I with jaybo
a lot of them cool do you
ever do like shows in Stockton uh uh I
did a show in Stockton before probably
like an SOB shot
I probably did a solo show like not too
long ago but yeah that'd be so much
going on I wouldn't even remember you've
been a part of some crazy man for
sure I probably